[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand plaisir de
recevoir enfin Mathieu d'Avignon que je
souhaite avoir un invité depuis très
longtemps et voilà donc c'est fait
Matthieu d'Avignon bonjour
vous êtes auteur de plusieurs
biographies et études sur le règne de
Louis XIV vous êtes directeur
scientifique du Centre de recherche du
château de Versailles et
on m'a rajouté cette petite chose qui
n'est pas une petite chose conseiller
historique de différentes productions
cinématographiques on peut dire la série
Versailles
pas non pas du tout parfait alors vous
avez littéraire je crois avec les
vallées de chambre de Louis XIV chez
Perrin après on a eu lu 14 et Versailles
le valet Louis XIV le fonctionnement
d'une résidence royale au 17e siècle etc
etc beaucoup de Louis XIV
le dernier en date qui
savent de cours mais il y a quand même
un lien évidemment c'est que vous
intéressez à une population particulière
arrêtez-moi si je me trompe que l'on
appelle les commencaux tout à fait alors
un peu barbare
c'est-à-dire que ce sont les officiers
qui mangeaient à la même table que celle
du roi alors là on est au Moyen-Âge
quand on dit ça c'est
à la même table avec la table alors
évidemment au 17e et 18e siècle il y a
bien longtemps que les officiers du roi
ne mangent plus à la table du roi mais
ils sont nourris au frais du roi et donc
ça fait partie de ce petit groupe de
domestiques qui sont très très proches
des souverains et qui pour eux ça la
représente un honneur d'être toujours
nourri au frais du roi et Marc cette
proximité avec les souverains donc voilà
moi ce qui m'intéresse vraiment c'est le
fonctionnement de Versailles de la cour
à partir ces personnes qui ont un rang
intermédiaire c'est pas tout à fait des
grands princesse etc c'est ni tout à
fait les petits valets qui balayent dans
les couloirs donc on est dans des
statues intermédiaires et surtout on
voit qu'à partir de ces personnages ils
connaissent des évolutions assez
incroyables notamment entre le 17e et le
18e siècle des évolutions de carrière
des évolutions de carrière oui justement
c'est moi c'est ce qui m'intéresse oui
et aussi j'imagine qu'ils savent des
choses que les autres ne savent pas
est-ce qu'ils sont logés près du près du
roi alors pour certains oui alors
l'occurrence ce sur lesquels j'ai
particulièrement travaillé donc c'est à
dire les valises chambre du roi ils sont
logés vraiment à proximité pour les
principaux ce qu'on appelle les premiers
ballets de chambre donc ils sont à
quelques mètres de la chambre à
disposition immédiate et alors justement
le premier valet de chambre c'est
Alexandre Bontemps donc vous êtes occupé
oui en fait moi c'est une dynastie qui
m'a intéressé depuis que j'ai fait ma
thèse en 2003 et vous l'avez évoqué j'ai
fait ce livre sur les vallées de chambre
de Louis XIV en 2004 voilà
et donc près de 20 ans après je suis
arrivé à la dernière des Bretons donc
cette charge on peut parler de charge
elle se transmet comment alors elle se
transmet de pair en fiche généralement
alors c'est pas obligatoire mais
généralement le roi perfusé et le Valais
non ça se trouve le Valais ça se refuse
pas c'est son père qui décide pour lui
c'est ce qu'on appelle une c'est ce
qu'on appelle une survivance et comme ça
quand même des intérêts financiers des
intérêts sociaux très importants
non crache pas dessus c'est le
secrétaire particulier du roi un petit
peu donc c'est celui qui fait écran
entre les courtisans
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on imagine alors
en plus il y a ce côté un peu moi qui
m'intéresse c'est cette distorsion de
sens entre l'officier et l'officiel
alors évidemment à l'époque évidemment
on se moque du terme de Valais que c'est
celui qui apporte le pot de chambre etc
et alors c'est effectivement celui qui
peut apporter le pot de chambre mais
c'est celui aussi qui
écran qui dit non vous ne verrez pas le
roi et donc il y a un vrai pouvoir c'est
lui qui c'est par lui que tout passe en
fait et qu'on essaye d'avoir une
audience auprès du roi donc c'est
quelqu'un de très très important de
façon officieuse et
qui finalement va obtenir des grâces
pour sa famille pour ses amis etc donc
moi c'est ce petit côté un petit peu
étonnant qui m'intéressait mais oui je
comprends et alors
du coup
cette votre héroïne là voilà la marquise
de je cours elle est l'arrière arrière
petite fille d'Alexandre Bontemps en
fait je l'ai trouvé par hasard moi il se
trouve que j'ai ma vieille Marotte et
que la boucle est bouclée j'ai travaillé
sur les bons temps et sur Alexandre en
particulier pendant de nombreuses années
et puis il y a 5 7 ans je me suis dit
tiens pour m'amuser je vais m'amuser à
faire toute la journée allergie des bons
temps depuis le premier premier valet de
chambre c'est à dire le père d'Alexandre
donc Jean-Baptiste
qui est né en 1584 à Gardanne et je me
suis dit je vais pousser jusqu'au bout
et voir tous ceux qui ont porté le nom
bon temps que ce soit des hommes ou des
femmes et il se trouve que le dernier
c'est une dernière donc j'ai regardé un
peu sa vie Marie-Charlotte Louise
Perrette
voilà et
j'ai vu qu'elle était née en 1761
qu'elle est morte en 1848 donc elle a
une longue destinée et finalement sa vie
a été assez intéressante donc je me suis
dit tiens pourquoi ne pas creuser et
finalement la boucle est bouclée au bout
de 20 ans voilà je crois que j'ai fait
le tour des montants et dites-moi vous
dites c'est l'alliance du pot de chambre
et de l'épée ça résume un peu tout ce
que vous venez de dire en fait
exactement parce que elle elle va se
marier évidemment dans la haute
aristocratie ça l'alliance du pot de
chambre
mais grâce à leur situation que toutes
les femmes des nez bon temps vont tout
quitter le monde de la domesticité
autant les hommes restent au service du
roi comme premier valet de chambre comme
premier valet de garde-robe etc s'il y
en a plusieurs alors que les femmes vont
épouser des noblio mais d'authentique
aristocrate mais elle va faire une
ascension spectaculaire parce qu'elle a
la chance d'être la nièce de Nicolas
Beaujon et Nicolas bojon c'est la folie
Beaujon c'est l'hôpital Beaujon
aujourd'hui c'est le propriétaire de
l'hôtel d'Évreux c'est-à-dire l'Élysée
après Madame de Pompadour c'est le
banquier de la cour il est richissime à
millions et il a pas d'enfant et donc
ces nièces deviennent très intéressantes
très jeune elle n'était pas elle avait
pas encore 25 ans et elle épouse déjà
elle est pousse en seconde noce le comte
de bicy donc déjà elle fait aussi
les Pontus de tiare donc c'est déjà une
famille très importante et c'est vrai
que on avait envisagé pour
Marie-Charlotte un homme de sa de son
rang et de son milieu c'est-à-dire le
marquis de chancelet le fils du marquis
de Chancenay qui était aussi de chambre
et puis finalement
on le devient par sa charge c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut être noble quand même pour
servir le roi donc on est anobli si on
est beau fils d'office et pour ses
descendants donc on avait envisagé un
mariage comme ça assez ce qu'on appelle
un mariage endoga c'est-à-dire dans le
même milieu social et puis finalement
quand sa mère s'est remarié quand même
avec le compte de Bissy donc la haute
aristocratie que tonton bourgeon est
présent et à mettre beaucoup d'argent on
se dit on la voit envisager envisager
plus haut puis finalement c'est par les
relations sauf que le compte de La
Châtre qu'elle épouse au départ on est
le double de son âge donc elle à peu
près 16 ans et demi l'une en a 36 37 au
moment du mariage donc ça peut prêt la
norme à l'époque et mais lui c'est une
noblesse qui remonte au 11e siècle on
est vraiment dans la très très haute
noblesse il se trouve qu'il fréquentait
le Beaujon pour des affaires d'argent
qu'il a plu il a des problème d'argent
mais comme tous ces grands seigneurs en
fait vivent dans sur un train un train
énorme ils empruntent sur leur nom donc
ils ont toujours de l'argent c'est comme
aujourd'hui quand on dit que Bernard
Tapie était pauvre ou avec des problèmes
d'argent en fait ils ont des problèmes
d'argent parce qu'ils sont endettés mais
ils vivent pas non plus dans des des
pièces etc mais bon il était content
d'avoir la petite qui arrive avec
beaucoup c'est voilà exactement et alors
du coup bah c'est un mariage qui marche
pas très très fort bah ils ont pas les
mêmes idées on va dire ils ont pas les
mêmes idéaux donc elle elle aspire à la
liberté on est au début des années moi
la fin des années 1770 il y a Voltaire
qui est passé par là il y a un certain
nombre de choses on est en plein dans
l'époque des Lumières et puis le roi et
la reine sont jeunes ils aspirent à plus
de liberté alors ce sont des gens qui ne
mesurent pas leur ambition de liberté
est-ce que ça peut peser sur leur
finalement ici magique que tout le monde
peut être heureux etc mais évidemment
pour être heureux il faut faire des
concessions et dès qu'on fait des
concessions forcément au bout d'un
moment le système qui est billets d'air
est plus ricéculaire peut s'effondrer et
eux ils ont des envies des voilà c'est
pour ça que j'ai appelé ça
le plaisir de vivre ou les libertés la
marquise de je cours alors c'est cette
notion de plaisir de vie parce qu'elle
correspond à la notion actuelle enfin
l'idée qu'on en a actuelle du plaisir de
vivre forcément c'est le en fait c'est
l'expression je suis parti de
l'expression de Talleyrand qui était son
premier amant son premier amour tout à
fait
juste avant son mariage ou au début de
son mariage elle s'est rapprochée de de
celui qui était encore cladé de Périgord
et donc le ministre talleyran et duquel
elle restera proche toute sa vie et elle
ça sera vraiment une une complicité
inamitié voir un amour exclusif
je pense qu'à jusqu'à la mort de
talleyran en 1838 et finalement
c'est lui qui a écrit c'est Guizot qui
rapporte ça le ministre Guizot qui
rapporte sous la Monarchie de Juillet
les propos de Talleyrand qui aurait dit
qui n'a pas connu la fin de leur sia
régime ne sait pas ce que c'est que le
plaisir de vivre et donc je suis parti
de là parce que ça fait aussi une boucle
c'est-à-dire on a talérant on a Guizot
qui est un protestant Guizot se
rapportait par le marquis de jocourt qui
est son deuxième mari donc je me suis
dit c'était intéressant et c'est vrai
que elle a une vie assez
tout ce que peut connaître une jeune
fille à ce moment-là c'est à dire avoir
un amant avoir un bâtard et voilà un
enfant naturel qu'elle reprend un autre
amant plusieurs amants vivre ouvertement
cet amour être empreinte des idées
neuves c'est à dire de
l'anglophilie c'est-à-dire d'avoir
l'envie d'une monarchie
constitutionnelle à l'anglais c'est ou
le Parlement a beaucoup plus de pouvoir
que le roi donc elle est dans cette idée
de faire ce qui lui plaît quand il lui
plaît donc c'est pour ça que j'ai appelé
ça le plaisir de vivre et ce plaisir de
vivre c'est celui que décrit talérant on
n'est pas aujourd'hui dans non plus dans
des grandes
liberté mais c'est une liberté par
rapport au conservatisme de l'époque
déjà celui qui avait avant et celui qui
va y avoir après tout à fait c'est
vraiment une petite parenthèse c'est une
parenthèse qui m'intéressait tout à fait
avec le divorce elle va divorcer elle va
profiter de la loi du divorce
faisant ménage à part avec son second
mari tout à fait c'est une petite
surprise que j'ai eu juste avant de
terminer le livre où je me suis dit
que un moment donné je me suis dit bon
allez on est en 1817 ils vont vivre
chacun autour du feu calmement ça y est
la vie se calme ils vont vivre leur
vieux jours autour de la cheminée puis
je me suis rendu compte que c'était pas
la même cheminée et que elle va
déménager pour aller habiter rue du Mont
Thabor juste à côté de l'hôtel de
Saint-Florentin qui est en fait l'hôtel
de Talleyrand et elle retrouve son
premier amant et son premier amant va
lui écrire des lettres d'amour à la fin
sont passionnantes et qui sont vraiment
toujours avec l'utilisation du mot je
vous aime de façon exclusive et il
termine ses lettres par je vous embrasse
et vous aime comme il y a 60 ans
et
elle est salonnière elle tient son salon
libéral bien sûr et
on vous écrivait elle n'obéit à aucune
règle ennuyeuse si vous l'écrivez mais
quelqu'un d'autre l'a dit je crois je
sais plus quelle est la
façon que c'est ça si c'est limité c'est
ça c'est de d'exprimer ses idées
politiques qui sont contre son rang et
d'ailleurs le marquis de chancenais qui
était premier à elle son premier fiancé
qui lui sera un journaliste dans la
presse satirique royaliste va revenir
sur ces dames qui renie leur caste d'or
et va la décrier tout ce qu'il peut de
toutes ces dames que ce soit madame de
Stalle que ce soit les la litholandale
toutes ces dames la princesse de Breuil
qui lors de la fête de la Fédération
c'est-à-dire le premier anniversaire de
du 14 juillet donc en 1790 vont pousser
leurs charrette pour élever l'hôtel de
la patrie etc donc on a des dames qui
affirment leur opinion bon au bout d'un
moment elles vont se rendre compte que
finalement
c'est pas très bon pour elle non plus
elle vous dirait elle aussi à l'étranger
bah oui c'est leur cas donc ils partent
en Angleterre et en fait on peut dire
qu'elle coche un peu elle a un moment de
sa vie toutes les cases de la modernité
possible à ce moment-là parce qu'après
ça va pu être la même non c'est plus la
même musique après et puis même il va y
avoir une chape qui va plus ou moins
tomber après la révolution mais elle va
continuer à vivre elle va être une sorte
de monument en fait de l'Ancien Régime
qu'on viendra voir elle et son mari qui
est le compte de je cours qui dev et qui
est le symbole du noble par excellence
qui connaît parfaitement les les règles
de l'Ancien Régime tu te sens des
références tout à fait bon ben écoutez
moi j'encourage tout le monde à se
plonger dans dans cette histoire de ce
couple de référence et qui est très
surprenant parce que c'est vraiment un
personnage qui sort du lot et ben je
comprends que vous ayez envie de vous
attacher à elle et nous nous faire part
de cette vie palpitante qui est
charnière de plein plein d'événements
historiques et de période différente
alors j'ai aussi ce petit livre qui est
sorti à pas très longtemps il y a un an
qui est vivre à la cour de Versailles en
100 questions voilà ça c'est extra avec
des beaucoup de concrets
trois pages par question et l'idée c'est
de vraiment donner un panorama de la vie
à la cour de Versailles entre le 17e et
le 18e siècle 18 par tout le monde voilà
sur les questions que les gens se posent
alors il se trouve j'ai fait mon choix
personnel on va se dire pourquoi il y a
pas tel alors c'est un choix personnel
mais je pense qu'il rejoint pas mal de
questions du public et sinon dernière
chose vous envisagez rien je sais pas on
a l'impression qu'il y a vraiment la
structure d'un film parce que on parle
toujours des mêmes du Barry
et des mois
que j'en parle à des amis de la
télévision justement ils me disent il y
a de matière à faire avec complètement
alors on est en train
d'essayer de voir si c'est possible mais
je suis un parce qu'elle a vraiment une
histoire hors du commun et qui nous
change des habitudes documentaires sur
sur sa vie qui est assez intéressantes
pour parler de la condition féminine à
la fin du 18e siècle puis même un film
parce que ça c'était quand même ça
serait bien je compte sur vous Mathieu
Delvina bah moi je compte sur les gens
qui seraient intéressés
merci à vous à très bientôt j'espère
avec plaisir merci au revoir à tous
merci de nous avoir suivi à très vite
[Musique]